Um
maybe maybe we should get started.
Um it's been a long time since we've all
been in the same place and I hope
everybody's doing well.
Um
today I'd like to talk about Spanner.
The reason to talk about this paper is
that it's a rare example of a um system
that provides distributed transactions
over data that's widely separated. That
is data that might be scattered all over
the internet in different data centers.
It's almost never done in um production
systems. Of course, it's extremely
desirable to be able to have
transactions. The programmers really
like it. Um and also extremely desirable
to have data spread all over the um
network for both for fault tolerance and
to ensure that data is near um that
there's a copy of the data near
everybody who wants to use it. Um
and um on the way to achieving this,
Spanner um used at least two neat ideas.
One is that they run two-phase commit,
but they actually run it over Paxos
replicated participants
um in order to avoid the problem with
two-phase commit that a crashed
coordinator can block everyone. Um and
the other interesting idea is that they
use synchronized time in order to have
very efficient readonly transactions. Um
and the system is is actually been very
successful. It's used a lot by many many
different services inside of Google.
It's uh been turned by Google into a a
product a service for their cloud-based
customers. Um and it's inspired um a
bunch of other research and other
systems both sort of by the example that
um these kind of wide area transactions
are possible and also specifically
there's um at least one open source
system cockroach DB that uses a lot of
explicitly uses a lot of the design um
the motivating use case the um reason
that the paper says they first kind of
uh started the design spanninner was
that they were already had a um well
actually they many big database systems
inside Google but their advertising
system in particular um the it data was
sharted over many many uh distinct MySQL
and big table databases and maintaining
that sharding uh was a just an awkward
and manual and timeconuming process in
addition their previous advertising
database system um didn't allow
transactions that spanned more than a
single uh basically more than a single
server um But they really wanted to be
able to have um to spread their data out
more widely for better performance and
to have transactions over the um
multiple shards of the data
um for their advertising database.
Apparently the workload was dominated by
readonly transactions. Um and you can
see this in table six where the um
there's billions of readonly
transactions and only millions of um of
read write transactions. So they're very
interested in um the performance of read
only of transactions that only do reads
and apparently they also required strong
consistency um that you know what
transactions in particular um so they
wanted serializable transactions and
they also wanted um external consistency
which means that if one transaction
commits
um and then after it finishes committing
another transaction starts the second
transaction needs to see any modific
ifications done by the first
um and this external consistency turns
out to be um uh interesting uh with with
replicated data. All right. So um I want
to draw out just the basic uh
arrangement sort of physical arrangement
of their servers that that Spanner uses.
Um it has the its servers are spread
over data centers um presumably all over
the world certainly all over the United
States. Um, and each piece of data is
replicated at multiple data centers. So,
um, the diagrams got to have, um,
multiple data centers. Let's say
there's, um, there's three data centers.
Really, there'd be many more. Oops.
Um,
so we have multiple data centers. Then
the data is sharded that it's broken up.
You can think of it as been being broken
up by key into um, and split over many
servers. So maybe there's one server
that um serves keys starting with A in
in this data center, another starting
with B um and so forth. Lots of lots of
starting over lots of servers. In fact,
every data center has or um any piece of
data is any shard is replicated at at
more than one data center. So there's
going to be another copy another replica
of the A keys and the B keys and so on.
the second data center and yet another
hopefully identical copy um of all this
data at the third data center. In
addition, each data center has m
multiple clients or they're clients of
Spanner. Um and what these clients
really are is web servers. So if an
ordinary human being sitting in front of
a web browser uh connects to some Google
service that uses Spanner, they'll
connect to some web server in one of the
data centers and that's going to be one
of these um
one of these Spanner clients.
All right. Um so that is replicated. The
replication is managed by Paxos. um in
fact really a variant of Paxos that has
leaders and is really very much like the
raft that we're all familiar with. Um
and each Paxos instance manages all the
replicas of a given shard of the data.
So this shard,
all the copies of this shard um form one
Paxos
uh group
and all the replicas of this shard form
another Paxos group and within each each
of these Paxos instances is um
independent has its own leader runs its
own version of the own uh of the own
instance of the Paxos protocol. Um and
the reason for the sharding and for the
independent
uh Paxos instances per shard is to allow
um parallel speed up and sort of a lot
of parallel throughput because there's a
vast number of clients you know which
are representing working on behalf of
web browsers. So this huge number
typically of concurrent requests um and
so it pays more immensely to split them
up over multiple shards and multiple
sort of Paxos
uh groups that are running in parallel.
Okay. And you can think of or each of
these Paxos groups has a leader um a lot
like raft. So maybe the leader for this
shard is in data is the replica in data
center one and the leader for this shard
might be the uh replica in data center 2
and um and so forth.
Um and uh you know so that means that if
you need to um if a client needs to do a
write it has to send that right to the
leader of the um of the shard whose data
it needs to write. Um just as with raft
these Paxos instances are what they're
really doing is sending out a log. The
leader is sort of replicating a log of
operations to all the followers and the
followers execute that log which is for
data is going to be reads and writes
sort of executes those logs. Um
all in the same order. Um
all right so uh the reason for these for
this setup um the sharding as I
mentioned is for throughput the multiple
copies in different data centers is for
two reasons one is um you want copies in
different data centers in case one data
center fails if you know maybe a power
fails to the entire city the data
center's in or there's an earthquake or
a fire or something you'd like um other
copies at other data centers that are
maybe not going to fail at the same
time. Um, and you know, there's a price
to pay for that because now the Paxos
protocol now has to talk maybe over long
distances to um talk to followers and in
different data centers. The other reason
to have data in multiple data centers is
that it may allow you to have copies of
the data near um all the different
clients that use it. So, if you have a
piece of data that may be read in both
California and New York, um maybe it's
nice to have a copy of that data, one
copy in California, one copy in New
York. um so that reads can be very fast
and indeed a lot of the focus of the
design is to make reads from the local
the nearest replica both fast and
correct. Um finally another interesting
interaction between Paxos and multiple
data centers is that Paxos like raft
only requires a majority
um in order to replicate a log entry and
proceed. And that means if there's one
slow or distant or flaky data center,
the Paxo system can keep chugging along
um and accepting new requests even if
one data center is um is being slow.
All right, so with this arrangement um
there's a couple of big challenges that
paper has to bite off. One is they
really want to do reads from local data
centers. Um but because they're using
Paxos and because Paxos only requires um
each log entry to be replicated on a
majority that means a minority of the
replicas may be lagging and may not have
seen the latest data that's been
committed by Paxos. Um, and that means
that if we allow clients to read from
the local replica for speed, they may be
reading outofdate data if their replica
happens to be in the minority that
didn't see the latest updates. So, they
have to since they're requiring
correctness, they're requiring this
external consistency idea um that every
read see the most up-to-date data, they
have to have some way of dealing with
the possibility that the local replica
may be lagging.
Um, another issue they have to deal with
is that a transaction may involve
multiple shards and therefore multiple
paxos groups. So you may be reading or
writing a single transaction may be
reading or writing multiple records in
the database that are stored in multiple
shards and multiple paxos groups. So
those have to be um we need distributed
transactions.
Um
okay so um I'm going to explain how the
transactions work. That's going to be
the kind of focus of the lecture.
Um, Spanner actually treats implements
readwrite transactions um quite
differently from readonly transactions.
So let me start with the read read
transactions which are um sort of a lot
more conventional in their design.
All right. Um
Right. So first read write transactions.
Uh let me just remind you what a
transaction looks like. Um so let's just
choose a simple one that's like
mimicking u bank transfer. So on one of
those client machines, a client of
Spanner, you'd run some code. You run
this transaction code. The code would
say I'm beginning a transaction. Um and
then it would say I want to read and
write these records. So maybe we have a
bank balance in database record X and we
want to you know increment we want to
increase this bank balance and decrease
Y's bank balance and oh that's the end
of the transaction and now the client
hopes the database will go off and
commit that. Um,
all right. So, I want to trace through
all the steps that uh that have to
happen in order to um in order for
Spanner to execute this readwrite
transaction. So, first of all, there's a
client in one of the data centers that's
driving this transaction. Um, so I'll
draw this client here. Let's imagine
that X and Y are on different shards.
Um, since that's the that's the
interesting case.
um and that those shards each of the two
shards is is replicated in uh uh three
different data centers. So, uh, we got
our three data centers here.
And at each data center, there's a, um,
a server that, uh, I'm just going to
write X for the replicas of the
shard that's holding X, the bank balance
for X, and Y for the these three
servers.
Spinner runs two-phase commit, just
totally standard two-phase commit and
two-phase locking almost exactly
um as described in the reading from last
week from the 6033 textbook. And the
huge difference um is that instead of
the participants and the transaction
manager being individual computers, the
participants in the track transaction
manager are um Paxos replicated
uh groups of servers for increased fault
tolerance. So that means just to remind
you that um the shard the three replicas
of the shard that stores X is really a
packless group. Same with these three
replicas storing Y. Um and we'll just
imagine that for each of these one of
the three servers is a leader. So let's
say the servant data center 2 is the
Paxo's leader for the X's shard and the
servant data center one is the Paxos
leader for uh Y's shard. Okay. So the
first thing that happens is that uh the
client picks a unique transaction ID
which is going to be carried on all
these uh messages so that the system
knows that um all the different
operations are associated with a single
transaction. First thing that is the
client has to read. So um despite the
way the code looks where it reads and
writes X and reads and write Y. In fact
um the way the code has transaction code
has to be organized. It has to do all
its reads first and then at the very end
do all the writes at the same time
essentially as part of the commit. Um so
the uh
the client has to do the reads. Um it
turns out that it um in order to
maintain locks since just as um as in
last week's 603 reading um every time
you read or write a data item the um
server responsible for it has to
associate a lock with that data item. Um
the locks are maintained the read locks
in spanner are maintained only in the
paxos leader. So uh when the client
transaction wants to readex, it sends a
redex request to um the leader of X's
shard and uh that leader of X's shard
returns the current value of X plus sets
a lock on X. Um and of course if the
lock's already set, then it won't
respond to the client until whatever
transaction currently has the data
locked releases the lock by committing.
Um, and then the leader for that shard
uh sends back the value of x to the
client. The client needs to read y. Got
lucky this time because the um assuming
the client's in data center one. The
leaders in the local
data center. So this read's going to be
a lot faster. Um the read sets the lock
on y in the paxos leader and then
returns. Okay. So now the client's done
all the reads. it does internal
computations and figures out the writes
it wants to do, what values it wants to
write to X and Y. Um, and so now the
client's going to send out the updated
values for the records um that it wants
to write and it does this all at once at
the end towards the end of the
transaction.
Um, so the first thing it does is it
chooses one of the Paxos groups to act
as the transaction coordinator.
um and it has to it chooses this in
advance and it's going to send out the
identity of the which Paxos group is
going to act as the transaction
coordinator. So let's assume it chooses
this Paxos group. I'll just put a double
box here to say that not only is this
server the leader of its Paxos group,
it's also acting as transaction
coordinator for this transaction. Then
the client sends out the um updated
values
that it wants to write. So it's going to
send a right x a right x request here
with a new value and the identity of the
transaction coordinator. Um
when each um the Paxos leader for each
written value receives the right
request, it um
uh
sends out a prepare message to its
followers and gets that into the Paxos
log. So that um I'll represent that by P
into the Paxus log because it's going to
commit to being able to or commit the
wrong word. it's promising to be able to
carry out this transaction that it
hasn't crashed for example and lost its
locks. Um so it sends out this prepare
message. It logs the prepare message
through Paxos when it gets a majority of
responses from the followers. Um
then this Paxos leader sends a yes to
the transaction coordinator saying yes
um I am promising to be able to carry
out my part of the transaction the right
to Y. Um
the and um notionally the transaction
the let's see the client also sends the
value to be written to Y
to um
uh Y's
Paxos leader and this server acting as
Paxos leader sends out prepare messages
um to his followers and logs it and
Paxos and waits for the acknowledgements
from majority already. Um and then you
can think of it as as the Paxos leaders
sending the
um transaction coordinator which is on
the same machine maybe the same program
a yes vote saying yes I can I can
commit. Okay. So when the transaction
coordinator
um gets responses from all the different
from the leaders of all the different
shards whose data um is involved in this
transaction. If they all said yes, then
the transaction coordinator can commit,
otherwise it can't. Um,
let's assume it decides to commit. Um,
at that point, the transaction
coordinator sends out um to the Paxos
followers a commit message saying,
"Look,
um, please remember that permanently in
the transaction log that um, we're
committing this transaction.
Um
and it also tells the um
leaders of the other Paxos groups
involved in the transaction then they
can commit as well. And so now um this
leader sends out commit messages to his
followers as well. as soon as the
commits are um
actually I think the leader the
transaction coordinator probably doesn't
send out the commit message to the other
shards until its commit is safe in the
log so that the transaction coordinator
is not guaranteed not to forget its
decision. Um once commits these commit
messages are committed into the Paxos
logs of the different shards, each of
those shards can actually execute the
rights that is place the written data um
and release the locks on
um the data items so that other
transactions can use them. Um
and then the transactions over.
So um first of all please feel free to
ask questions if uh um by raising your
hand if you if you have questions.
Okay. So there's some points um to
observe about the design so far which is
you know only covered the readr aspect
of transactions. One is that it's the
the locking that is ensuring
serializability.
that is if two transactions conflict
because they use the same data, one has
to completely wait for the other to
release it locks before it can proceed.
So it's using so Spanner is using
completely standard two-phase locking um
in order to get serializability
and completely standard two-phase commit
to get distributed transactions.
The two-face commits widely hated um
because if the transaction coordinator
should fail or become unreachable then
any transactions it was um managing
block indefinitely until the transaction
coordinator comes back up and they block
with locks held. So people have been in
general very reluctant to use two-phase
commit in the real world because it's
blocking.
Spanner solves this by replicating the
transaction manager. The transaction
manager itself is a Paxos replicated
state machine. So everything it does
like for example remember whether it's
committed or not is replicated into the
Paxos log. So if the uh leader here
fails
um even though it was managing the
transaction because it's raft replicated
either of these two replicas can spring
to life take over leadership and also
take over um being the transaction
manager and they'll have in their log if
the transaction manager decided to
commit. any leader that takes over will
see a commit in its log and be able to
then tell the other right away tell the
other um participants in the two-face
commit that look oh this transaction was
committed. So this effectively
eliminates the um
problem with two-face commit that it can
block with locks held if there's a
failure. Um and this is a really big
deal because this problem basically
makes two-face commit otherwise
completely unacceptable for any sort of
large scale system that has a lot of
parts that might fail.
The other another thing to note is that
there's a huge amount of messages on um
in this diagram here. Um and that means
and many of them are across data
centers. And so some of these messages
that go between the shards or between a
client and the shard whose leader is
another data center may take many
milliseconds. Um and in a world in which
you know computations take nanconds this
is uh a potentially pretty grim expense.
Um
and indeed you can see that in from in
table six and table six if you look at
it it's describing the performance of a
um
Spanner deployment where the different
replicas are on different sides of the
United States east and west coast and um
it takes about a 100 milliseconds to do
a um complete a transaction where the
different replicas involved are on
different coasts. That's a huge amount
of time. That's a tenth of a second. Um
it's maybe not quite as bad as it may
seem because the throughput of the
system since it's sharded and it can run
a lot of non-conlicting transactions in
parallel the throughput may be very hard
high um but the delay for individual
transactions very significant I mean 100
milliseconds is maybe somewhat less than
a human is going to notice but if you
have to do a couple of them um to say
generate a web page or carry out a human
instruction it's starting to be an
amount of time that will be noticeable
and start to be bothering bothersome Um
on the other hand for I think I suspect
for many uses of Spanner all the
replicas might be in um in the same city
or sort of across town and there the
much faster times that you can see in
table three um are relevant and there
it's table three shows that it can um
complete transactions where the data
centers are nearby in you know I think
it's 14 milliseconds instead of 100
milliseconds so that's not quite so bad.
Um, nevertheless, these read write
transactions are slow enough that we
like to avoid um the expense if we
possibly can.
Um, and so that's going to take us to
read only transactions. It turns out
that if you're not writing, that is if
you know in advance that all of the
operations in a transaction are
guaranteed to be reads, then Spanner has
a much faster, much more streamlined,
much less meth message intensive scheme
um for executing readonly transactions.
Okay. So, so readonly transactions um
start a new topic here. The read only
transactions work although they rely on
some information from readwrite
transactions. The design is quite
different from
um the read the readwrite transactions.
Um and Spanner eliminates two big costs
um in its readonly transaction design.
Eliminates two of the costs that were
present in readwrite transactions. First
of all, as I mentioned, it reads from
local replicas. Um and so if you have a
replica as long as there's a replica the
data the client needs the transaction
needs in the local data center you can
do the read and uh from that local
replica which may take a small fraction
of a m millisecond to talk to instead of
maybe dozens of of milliseconds if you
have to go cross country. So it can read
from local replicas. Um but note you
know again the danger here is that any
given replica may not be up to date. Um
so there has to be a story for that.
And the other big um savings in the
readonly design is that it doesn't use
locks. It doesn't use two-face commit.
Um and it doesn't need a transaction
manager.
Um and this avoids things like cross
data center or inter data center
messages uh to Paxos leaders. Um and
because no locks are taken out, not only
does that make the readonly transactions
faster, but it avoids slowing down read
only read write transactions because
they don't have to rate for locks held
by readonly transactions. Um and just to
kind of preview why this is important to
them, uh tables three and six show a 10
times latency improvement for readonly
transactions compared to readwrite
transactions. Um so the readonly design
gets them a factor of 10 boost in
latency.
Um and then much less complexity. So
almost certainly far more throughput as
well. And the big challenge is going to
be how to square the uh you know realign
transactions don't do a lot of things
that were require required on read read
transactions to get serializability. Um
so we need to f uh they needed to find a
way to kind of square this increased
efficiency with correctness. Um and so
there's really two uh main correctness
constraints that they wanted to um have
read only transactions imposed. The
first is that they like all transactions
they still need to be serializable.
Um and what that means is that um even
though just to review even though uh the
system may execute transactions
concurrently in parallel um the results
that a bunch of concurrent transactions
must yield both in terms of sort of
values that they return to the client
and modifications to the database. the
results of a bunch of concurrence
transactions must be the same as some
one at a time or serial u execution of
those transactions.
Um, and for readonly transactions, what
that essentially means is that the an
entire all the reads of a readonly
transaction must effectively fit neatly
between um all the rights of a bunch of
transactions that um can be viewed as
going before it and and it must not see
any of the rights of the transactions
that we're going to view as as going
after it. So we need a way to sort of
fit the read all the reads of a
transaction read only transaction kind
of neatly between readrs.
Um
the other big uh constraint that the
paper talks about is that they want
external consistency.
Um and what this means
um
it's actually
uh equivalent to
um linearizability that we've seen
before. What this really means is that
if one transaction commits, finishes
committing and another transaction
starts after the first transaction
completed in real time um then the
second transactions required to see the
rights done by the first transaction.
Another way of putting that is that
transactions even readonly transactions
should not see stale data. You know, if
there's a committed write from a
completed transaction that's prior to
the read only transaction, prior to the
start of the read only transaction, the
readine transaction is required to see
that right. Um
okay, so um this is actually none of
neither of these is particularly
surprising. the standard databases some
like my SQL or something for example um
um can be configured to provide this
kind of consistency. So in a way it's
sort of the consistency that if you
didn't know better this is exactly the
consistency that you would expect of a
of a straightforward system. Um and the
you know you don't have to have it but
it makes programmers lives it makes it
much easier to uh produce correct
answers you know otherwise the if you
don't have this kind of consistency then
the programmers are responsible for kind
of programming around whatever anomalies
the database may provide. So this is
like a this is sort of the gold standard
of of correctness.
Okay. So
um
let's I want to going to talk about how
read only transactions work. It's a bit
of a complex story. So, um I think what
I'd like to talk about first is to just
um consider what would happen if we did
just absolutely the stupidest thing and
had the readonly transactions
um not do anything special to achieve
consistency, but just read the very
latest copy of the data. So every time a
readonly transaction does a read um we
could just have it look at the local
replica and find the current most
up-to-date um copy of the data right
that would be very straightforward um
very low overhead. So we need to
understand why that doesn't work um
in order. So this is uh
so why not
read the just the the latest value.
And so maybe we'll imagine that the
transaction is a transaction that simply
reads um
X and Y and prints them.
It's read only. We're going to print y
and we'll just print x comma y.
Okay. So um I want to show you an
example of a situation in which um read
having this transaction just simply read
the latest value yields um incorrect not
uh not serializable results. So so we
have three transactions running t1,
t2,
t3. Um T3 is going to be our
transaction. T1 and T2 are uh
transactions that are are rewrite
transactions. Um so let's say that uh T1
writes X
and writes Y and then commits. And you
know maybe it's a bank transfer
operation. So it's transferring money
from X to Y. And we're printing X and Y
because we're doing an audit of the bank
to try to make sure it hasn't lost
money. Let's imagine that transaction
two um also does another transfer
between
uh balances X and Y and then commits.
And now we have our transaction
transaction T3. It's it needs to read X
and Y. Um so it's going to have a read
of X. Let's say the read of X um happens
at this point in time. And so I'm uh the
way I'm drawing these diagrams is that
real time moves to the right. wall clock
time, the kind of time you'd see on your
watch moves to the right. So the read of
X happens here after transaction one
completes before transaction two starts.
Um and let's say T3 is running on a slow
computer. So it only manages to issue
the read of Y uh much later.
So the way this is going to play out is
that transaction 3 will see the y value
that t1 wrote but the x value that t2
wrote.
Um assuming it uses this uh dubious
procedure of simply reading the latest
value that's in the database. Um, and so
this is not serializable because um,
well, we know that any serial order that
could exist must have um, T1
uh, followed by T2. There's only two
places T3 could go. So T3 could go here.
Um but T3 can't fit here because if T3
was second in the equivalent serial
order then it shouldn't see rights by T2
which comes after it. It should see um
the value of Y produced by T1 but it
doesn't right it sees the value produced
by T3 by T2. So this is not an
equivalent. This serial order wouldn't
produce the same results. The only other
one available to us is this one. um this
serial order would get the same value
for y that t3 actually produced but um
if this was the serial order then t3
should have seen the value written by t2
but it actually saw the value written by
t1. So this execution is not equivalent
to any one at a time serial order. So um
this is like there's something broken
um about read simply reading the latest
value. So we know that doesn't work. You
know what we're really looking for of
course is that either the our our
transaction either reads the uh both
values at this point in time or it reads
both values at this point in time.
Um okay. So um
the
uh approach that um
expand our taste of this it's it's a
somewhat complex. Um the first big idea
is an existing idea. Um it's called
snapshot isolation.
And
um
the way I'm going to describe this is
that um let's imagine that all the
computers involved had synchronized
clocks. That is the you know they all
have a clock the clock yields uh yields
a sort of wall clock time like oh it's
um 1:43 in the afternoon on uh April 7th
2020. So that's what we mean by it a
wall clock time a time. So let's assume
that all the computers assume even
though this isn't true that all the
computers involved have uh synchronized
times. Furthermore, let's imagine that
every transaction is assigned a
particular time, a time stamp. Um,
and
um,
okay. So, we have these timestamps
there. There are wall clocks times taken
from these synchronized clocks for read
write transaction. its time stamp is um
I'm going to say just for this uh for
this simplified design is the real time
at um at the commit
and for read for a um or at the time at
uh which the transaction manager starts
the commit and for a readonly
transaction um that time stamp is equal
to the start time.
Um
all right so every transaction has a
time and we're going to design our
system our snapshot isolation system
gets is designed to execute as if to get
the same results as if all the
transactions had executed in timestamp
order. So we're going to assign the
transactions each transaction a time
stamp and then we're going to arrange
the executions so that um the
transactions get the results as if they
had executed in that order. So given the
time stamps, we sort of need to um have
an implementation that will kind of
basically honor the timestamps um and
basically you know show each transaction
the data sort of as it existed at at its
um time stamp. Okay. So the way that
this works um
uh for readonly transactions
um is that each replica when it stores
data it actually has multiple versions
of the data. Um so we have a multiple
version
um database
every database record has um you know
maybe if it's been written a couple
times it has a separate copy of that
record for each of the times it's been
written each one of them associated with
the um timestamp of the transaction that
wrote it.
Um
and um then the basic strategy is that
readonly transactions when they when a
readonly transaction does a read it's
already allocated itself a time stamp um
when it started and so it accompanies
its read request with its time stamp and
the whatever uh server um you know that
stores the replica of the data that the
transaction needs. It's going to look
into its multi-version database and find
the um record that's being asked for
that has the highest time that's still
less than the time stamp um specified by
the readonly transaction. So that means
it be only transaction sort of sees data
the latest data as of the time as of its
time chosen time stamp. Um
okay so this is for um this snapshot
isolation idea works for readonly
transactions or Spanner uses it for
readonly transactions. Spanner uses
still uses um two-phase locking and
two-phase commit for read write
transactions. And so the readr
transactions allocate timestamps for
themselves at commit time but other than
that they work in the usual way with
locks and two-phase commit. Whereas the
readonly transactions um access the
multiple versions in the database and
get the version that's you know written
by the um has the time stamp that's
highest but still less than the readonly
transactions time stamp. And where this
is going to get us is that you know
readon transactions will see all the
rights of of readwrite transactions with
lower time stamps and none of the writes
of rewrite transactions with higher time
time stamps. Um okay. So, uh how would
snapshot isolation um work out for our
example? Um
um the example that I had here before
in which um we had a failure of serial
serializability because um
the reading transaction
um read before read values that were not
between any two of the readrite
transactions. Okay. So this is now our
example but with um snapshot isolation.
I'm showing you this to show that the
snapshot isolation technique um solves
our problem
causes the readonly transaction to uh be
serializable. So again we have these two
read write transactions T1 and T2 and we
have our transaction that's a readonly
transaction
T1 and T2 um
uh write as before they write and they
commit um
but now they're allocating themselves
timestamps as of the commit time. So um
in addition to using two-phase commit
and two-face locking, these rewrite
transactions allocate a time stamp. So
let's imagine that at uh the time of the
commit, T1 looked at the clock and saw
that it um the time was 10. And I'm
going to use times of 10 and 20 and
whatnot. Um but you know, you should
imagine times as being real times like
4:00 in the morning on a given day. So
um let's say that T1 sees the time as 10
when it committed. Um and T2
um sees that at the commit time the time
was 20. So I'm going to write these
transactions chosen time stamp after the
at sign. Um then the uh database uh
storage systems the spanner storage
systems are going to store um when
transaction one does its writes they're
going to store a new sort of not instead
of overwriting the current value they're
just going to add a new copy of this
record u with the time stamp. So it's
going to the database is going to store
away a new record that says the value of
x at time 10 is whatever it happens to
be let's say nine. The value of uh
record y at time 10 is say 11. Maybe
we're doing a transfer from x to y.
Similarly t2 chose time stamp of 20
because that was the real time at commit
time and the database is going to
remember a new set of records in
addition um to these old ones. just
going to say x at time 20
um if we did a another transfer from x
to y and y at time 20
equals 12. So now I have two copies of
each record at different times. Now t
transaction 3 is going to come along and
again it starts
um at about this time and does a read of
x and again it's going to be slow so you
know it's not going to get around to
reading y until much later much later in
real time however when transaction 3
started it chose a timestamp by looking
at the uh looking at the current time
and and so let's say so we know in real
time that transaction 3 started after
transaction one and before transaction
two, we know it's got to have chosen a
transaction time somewhere between 10
and 20. Um, and let's suppose it started
at time 15 and chose time stamp 15 for
itself. So that mean when it does the
read of X, it's going to send a a
request to the local replica that holds
X and it's going to accompany it with it
time stamp of 15. It's going to say,
please give me the latest data as of
time 15. Um but of course transaction
two hasn't executed yet and but
nevertheless the highest time stamp copy
of X um is the one from time 10 written
by transaction one. So we're going to
get um nine for this one. Time passes.
Transaction two commits. Now transaction
three does it second read. Again it
accompanies it the read request with its
own time stamp of 15. Sends it to the
servers. Now the servers have two
records. But again, because the server
gets transaction 3's time stamp of 15,
it looks at its records and say, "Ha, 15
sits between these two, I'm going to
return the highest time stamp record for
X for Y." Um, that's less than the
requested time stamp, and that's still
uh the version of Y from time 10. So,
the read of Y will return 11.
That is the read of X essentially
happens at this time. But because we
remembered a time stamp and we have the
database keep data as of um different
times it was written, it's as if both
reads happened um at time 15 instead of
one at time 15 and one later. Um and now
you'll see that in fact this just
essentially emulates a serial one at a
time execution in which the order is
timestamp order. transaction one, then
transaction two, sorry, then transaction
three,
then transaction two. That is the serial
order that is equivalent to the results
that were actually produced is the time
stamp order of 10, 15, 20.
All right. Um, okay. So, that's a kind
of simplified version of what Spanner
does for readonly transactions.
Um
there's more complexity which I'll get
to in a minute. Um one question you
might have is why it was okay for
transaction 3 to read an old value of Y.
That is it issued this read of Y at this
point in time. The freshest data for Y
was this value 12. But the value it
actually got was intentionally a stale
value. Not the freshest value but the
value from a while ago. this value 11.
So why is that okay? Why is it okay not
to be using the freshest um version of
the data and um the kind of technical
justification for that is that
transaction two and transaction 3 are
concurrent that is they overlap in time.
So the sort of time extent of
transaction two is here and the time
extent of transaction three is here.
they're concurrent and the rules for
linearizability and external consistency
are that if two transactions are
concurrent
um then the serial order that the
database is allowed to use can be can
put the two transactions in either order
and here the database spanner has chosen
to put transaction three before
transaction two in the serial order.
Okay, I think we Robert, we Yeah, we
have a student question. Does external
consistency like with time stamps always
imply strong consistency?
Um,
uh, I'm going to guess.
Um, I think so. if strong consistency
um strong consistency usually what
people mean by that is a linearizability
and I believe the definition of
linearizability and uh external
consistency are the same. So I would say
yes
and another question how does this not
absolutely blow up storage? That is a
great question and the answer is it
definitely blows up storage and the
reason is that um now the storage system
has to keep multiple copies um of data
records that have been recently modified
multiple times. Um and that's definitely
expense both um both this cost in
storage and space on the disk and in
memory and also it's just like an added
layer of bookkeeping um you know now
lookups have to consider the time stamps
as well as keys. Um
the storage expense I think is um not as
great as it could be because the system
discards old records. The paper does not
say what the policy is. Um but
presumably
well it must be discarding old records.
Um certainly if the only reason for the
multiple records is to implement
snapshot isolation of these kinds of
transactions then you don't really need
to remember values too far in the past.
um because
um you only need to remember values back
to the sort of earliest time that a that
a transaction could have started at
that's still running now. And if your
transactions mostly are always finish or
force to finish by killing them or
something um within say one minute. If
no transaction can take longer than a
minute, then you only have to remember
the last minute of of versions in the
database. Now, in fact, the paper
implies that they remember data farther
back than that because it um appears
they support
intentionally support um these snapshot
reads which allow them to support the
notion of seeing, you know, data from a
while ago, you know, yesterday or
something. Um but they don't say what
the
what the garbage collection policy is
for old values. So I don't know how
expensive it would be for them.
Okay.
Okay. So the uh the the justification
for why it's legal is that in external
consistency the the only rule that
external consistency imposes is that if
one transaction has completed then a
transaction that starts after it must
see its rights. So T1 maybe T1
completed. Let's say that T1 completed
at this time and T3 started just after
it. Maybe external consistency would
demand that T3 sees T1's rights. But
since T2 definitely didn't finish before
T3 started, we have no obligation under
external consistency for T3 to see T2's
rights. And indeed the in this example,
it does not. So it's actually legal.
Um
okay another problem that comes up um is
that
uh the transaction T3 is needs to read
data as of a particular time stamp but
um you know the reason why this is
desirable is that we're it allows us to
read from the local replica in the same
data center but maybe that local replica
is in a minority of Paxos followers that
didn't see the latest log records the
leader so maybe our local replica uh
maybe it's never even seen, you know,
never saw these rights to X and Y at
all. It's still back at a version from
time, you know, five or six or seven. Um
and so if we don't do something clever
when we ask for the sort of highest
version
uh record, you know, less than time
stamp 15, we may get some much older
version that's not actually the value
produced by transaction one, which we're
required to see.
Um so the way Spanner deals with this is
with their notion of safe time. Um
and
uh the scoop is that each replica
remembers you know it's getting log
records from its Paxos's leader and the
log records um it turns out that the
paper arranges so that the leader sends
out log records in strictly increasing
timestamp order. So a replica can look
at the very last log record it's gotten
from its leader to know uh how up to
date it is. So um if I ask for a value
as of time stamp 15, but the um replica
has only gotten log entries from a paxos
leader up through time stamp 13, the
replica is going to make us delay. It's
not going to answer um until it's gotten
a log record with time stamp 15 from the
leader. Um, and this ensures that
replicas don't answer um, a request for
a given time stamp until they're
guaranteed to know everything from the
leader um, up through that time stamp.
And so this may delay um,
this may delay the reads.
Okay.
Um
so the next question I've been assuming
I assumed in this discussion that the
clocks and all the different servers are
perfectly synchronized. So everybody's
clock says you know 10:01 and 30 seconds
at exactly the same time. Um but it
turns out that you can't um synchronize
clocks
that precisely.
um
you
it's basically impossible to get
perfectly synchronized clocks. Um
and the reasons are uh reasonably
fundamental. Um
so the topic is time synchronization.
Just sort of making sure clocks say the
same real time value. Different clocks
read the same value. Um the
um
um I'll I'll the sort of fundamental
problem is that time is defined as
basically the time it says on a
collection of highly accurate expensive
clocks in a set of government
laboratories. So we can't directly read
them. All that we can know is that um
these government laboratories can
broadcast the time in various ways. Um
and uh the broadcasts take time and so
at some time later some possibly unknown
time later we hear these announcements
of what the time is and we all may all
hear these announcements at different
times due to varying delays. Um so um
actually first I want to consider the
problem of what the impact is if on
snapshot isolation um if the clocks are
not synchronized
which they won't be.
Okay. So what if clocks aren't synced?
Um there's actually no problem at all
for the spanner's readwrite transactions
because the readwrite transactions use
locks and two-phase commit. Um they're
not actually using snapshot isolation.
So they don't care. So the readwrite
transactions will still be serialized by
the lock the two-phase locking
mechanism. Um so we're only interested
in what happens for an for readonly
transaction. Um so let's suppose a
readonly transaction um
uh chooses a time stamp that is too
large.
So that is far in the future. You know
it's now 12:01 p.m. and it chooses a
time stamp at say 1:00 p.m. Um
so if a transaction's chosen time stamps
too big um that's actually not that bad.
Um what it'll mean is that it'll do read
requests. It'll send a read request to
some um replica. The replica will say,
"Wait a minute, your you know your clock
is far is far greater. Your time stamp
is far greater than the last log entry I
saw from my Paxos leader. So I'm going
to make you wait until the Paxos the
time and the log entry from the Paxos
leader catches up to the time you've
requested. I'm only going to respond
then." So this is correct but slow.
The reader will be forced to wait. Um
but that's not the worst thing in the
world. But what happens if we have a
readonly transaction
um and its time stamp is too small.
Um and this would correspond to its
clock being well either set wrong so
that it's set in the past or maybe it
was originally set correctly but the
clock its clock ticks too slowly. Um the
problem with this this is a obviously
causes a correctness problem. This will
cause a violation of external
consistency because um the multi-verion
databases you'll give it a time stamp
that's far in the past say an hour ago
and the database will read you a value
associated with it the time stamp from
an hour ago which may ignore more recent
writes. So using a assigning a time
stamp to a transaction that's too small
will cause you to miss recent committed
rights.
Um, and
that's a violation of external
consistency. So, not
not externally consistent. So, um, so we
actually have a problem here. Um, the
assumption that the clocks were
synchronized is in fact a a very serious
assumption. And the fact that you cannot
count on it means that unless we do
something, um, the system's going to be
incorrect.
All right.
So um so can we synchronize clocks
perfectly? Right. That would be the
ideal thing. Um and if not why not? So
um so what about clock synchronization?
the uh as I mentioned um where time
comes from is a it's actually collection
of the kind of median of a collection of
clocks in government labs um the way
that we hear about time is that it's
broadcast by various protocols sometimes
by radio protocols like basically what
GPS is doing for Spanner is a GPS acts
as a radio broadcast system that
broadcasts the current time from some
government lab through the GPS satellite
ites to GPS receivers sitting in the um
uh Google machine rooms. And there's a
number of other radio protocols like WWB
is another older radio protocol for
broadcasting the current time. And
there's newer protocols like there's
this NTP protocol that operates over the
uh um
uh internet that also is in charge of um
basically broadcasting time. So the sort
of system diagram is that um there's
some government labs and the government
labs uh with their accurate clocks
define a universal notion of time that's
called UTC.
So we have UTC coming from some clocks
and some labs. Then we have um some you
know radio or internet broadcast or
something. For the case of um
um
spanner, it's the we can think of the
government labs broadcasting to GPS
satellites.
Um the satellites in turn broadcast and
they broadcast to you know the millions
of GPS receivers that are out there. Um
you can uh buy GPS receivers for you
know a couple hundred bucks that will
decode the timestamps in the um
in the uh GPS signals and sort of keep
you up to date with exactly what uh the
time is corrected for the propagation
delay between the government labs and
the GPS satellites and also corrected
for the delay between the GPS satellites
and your current position. Um and then
there's um in each data center
there's a GPS receiver
um that's connected up to what the paper
calls a time master which is some
server. There's going to be more than
one of these for data center in case one
fails. Um and then there's all the
hundreds of servers in the data center
that are running Spanner either as
servers or as clients. Um each one of
them is going to um periodically send a
request saying oh what time is it to the
local one or more usually more than one
in case one fails to the time masters
and the time master will reply with oh
you know I think the current time as
received from GPS is such and such. Um
now
um built into this unfortunately is a
certain amount of uncertainty.
Um
and the primary sources of uncertainty I
think well there's there's fundamentally
uncertainty in that we don't actually
know how far we are for the G from the
GPS satellites exactly. Um so the you
know radio signals take some amount of
time even if the GPS satellite knew
exactly what time it is. The signals
take some time to get to our GPS
receiver. If we're not sure what that
is, that means that when the G we get a
a message from the radio message from
the GPS satellite saying exactly 12:00,
you know, if the propagation delay might
have been, you know, a couple of
nanconds, that means that we're uh
actually the propagation delay is much
more than that. It's really the
uncertainty in the propagation delay. Um
means that we're not really sure exactly
whether it's 12:00 or a little before, a
little after. In addition, um all the
times that time is communicated, there's
added uncertainty um that you have to
account for. And in the biggest sources
are that when a server sends a request
after a while, it gets a response. If
the response says it's exactly 12
o'clock,
but um the amount but say a second pass,
you know, between when the server sent
the request and when it got the
response, all the server knows is that
even if the master had the correct time,
all the server knows is that um
the time is within a second of 12:00. um
because maybe the maybe the request was
instant but the reply was delayed or
maybe the request was delayed by a
second and the response was instant. So
all we really know is that it's between
you know 12:00 and 0 seconds and 12:00
and 1 second. Um,
okay. So, um, there's always this
uncertainty.
Um, and in order to, which we really
can't ignore though, because the
uncertainties, we're talking about
milliseconds here. Um, and we're going
to find out that these that the
uncertainty in the time goes directly to
the these how long these safe weights
have to be and how long some other
pauses have to be, the commit weight, as
we'll see. Um
uh so you know uncertainty on the level
of milliseconds is a serious problem.
The other big uncertainty is that each
of these servers only requests the
current time from the master every once
in a while say every minute or however
often. Um and between that the each
server runs its own local clock that
sort of keeps the time starting with the
last time from the master. those local
clocks are actually pretty bad um and
can drift by things by milliseconds
between times that the server talks to
the master um and so the system has to
sort of add the the unknown
um but estimated drift of the local
clock um to the uncertainty of the time.
So um in order to capture this
uncertainty and account for it, uh
um Spanner uses this true time scheme
in which when you ask what time it is,
what you actually get back is one of
these TT interval things
which is a pair
um of an earliest time
and a latest earliest time is the ear
early
um earliest the time could possibly be
and the second is the latest the time
can possibly be. Um so when the
application
you know makes this library call that
asks for the time it gets back this pair
all it knows is that the current time is
somewhere between earliest and latest
and so you know earliest might be in
this case earliest might be 12:00 and
latest might be 12:00 and 1 second just
um are guaranteed that the that the
correct time isn't less than earliest
and isn't greater than latest.
Well, we don't know where between that
it lies.
Okay, so this is what um
when a transaction asks the system what
time it is, this is this is what the
transaction actually gets back from the
time system. And now um
let's return our original problem was
that if the clock was too slow that a uh
readonly transaction might read data too
far in the past and that it wouldn't
read data from a recent committed
transaction. So we need to know what
we're looking for is how um Spanner uses
these TT intervals and its notion of
true time in order to ensure that
despite uncertainty on what time it is
um transaction
uh obey external consistency that is a
read only transaction is guaranteed to
see um rights done by a transaction rate
uh transaction that completed before us.
And there are
um two rules that the paper talks about
that conspire to um
force this and the two rules which are
in section 412. One of them is the start
rule
and
the other is uh commit weight.
The sort rule tells us what um time
stamps transaction what time stamps
transactions choose. Um and basically
says that a transactions time stamp has
to be equal to the latest half of the um
true time current time. So this is
tt.now call which returns one of those
earliest latest pairs. That's the
current time and a transactions time
stamp has to be the latest
that is it's going to be a time that's
guaranteed not to have happened yet
because the true time is between
earliest and latest. Um and for a uh
readon transaction
um it's assigned the latest time as of
um it's the time it starts and for a
read write transaction it's assigned a
time stamp um this latest value as of
the time it starts to commit.
Um
okay so the start rule says this is how
Spanner chooses time stamps. The commit
weight rule um only for readwrite
transactions
uh says that
um
when a a transaction coordinator is uh
you know collects the votes and sees
that it's able to commit and and chooses
a time stamp after it chooses this time
stamp it's required to delay to wait a
certain amount of time before it's
allowed to actually commit and write the
values and release locks. Um
so a readwrite transaction um has to
delay
until
um its time stamps that it chose when it
was starting to think about commit is
less than the current time
um
earliest.
Sorry.
So what's going on here is that it sits
in a loop calling ts.now now and it
stays in that loop until the time stamp
that it had chosen at the beginning of
the commit process is less than the
current time's earliest half. And what
this guarantees is that um
since now the earliest possible
correct time is greater than the
transaction's time stamp. That means
that um when this loop is finished, when
the commit weight is finished, this time
stamp of the transaction is absolutely
guaranteed to be in the past.
Okay. So, um how does the system
actually make use of these two rules
um in order to enforce
um
external consistency for read only
transactions? I want to go back to our
or I want to um
um
cook up a uh somewhat simplified
uh scenario in order to illustrate this.
Um so I'm going to imagine that the
writing transactions only do one write
each just to reduce the complexity.
Let's say that there's two uh readwrite
transactions. So we have T0
and T1 are readwrite transactions and um
they both write X and we have a T2 which
is going to read X and we want to make
sure that T2 sees um you know it's going
to use snapshot isolation at time
stamps. We want to make sure that it
sees the latest written value. Um
so we're going to imagine that T2 does a
write of X and writes one to X um and
then commits
We're going to imagine that um
sorry T1 writes X and commit. T2 also
writes X
writes a value two to X. Um and we need
to distinguish between prepare and
commit. So we're going to say it it's
really a prepare that the transaction
chooses its uh
time stamp. So this is the point at
which it chooses its time stamp and then
it commits sometime later. Um and then
we're imagining by assumption that T2
starts after T1 finishes. So it's going
to read X
um afterwards and we want to make sure
it sees two. All right. So um let's
suppose that uh T0 chooses a time stamp
of one.
Um commits writes the database.
Let's say t1 starts
um at the time it chooses a time stamp
it it's going to get some it's not get a
single number from the two time system
really gets a range of numbers
um
you know an earliest and a latest
value. Let's say at the time it chooses
its time stamp, it um the range of
values, the earliest uh time it gets is
one and the latest field in the current
time is 10. Um
so the uh the rule says that it must
choose 10. The latest value is it time
stamp. So T1 is going to commit with
time stamp 10.
Now, it can't commit yet because the
commit wait rule says it has to wait
until its time stamp is guaranteed to be
in the past. So, uh transaction one is
going to sit there keep asking what time
is it? What time is it until it gets an
interval back um that doesn't include
time 10. So, at some point um it's going
to ask what time it is and it's going to
get a time that where the earliest value
is 11 and the latest is I don't know
what I'd say 20. And now it's going to
say aha now I know that my time stamp is
guaranteed to be in the past and I can
commit. Uh so T1 will actually this is
its commit weight period to sit there
and uh wait for a while before it
commits.
Okay. Now after commits uh transaction 2
comes along and wants to read X. It's
going to choose a time stamp. Also um
we're assuming that it starts after T1
finishes because that's an interesting
scenario for external consistency. So
let's say when it asks for the time
um it asks at a time after time 11. So
it's going to get back an interval that
includes time 11. Um so let's suppose it
gets back an interval that um goes from
time 10 the earliest and time uh 12 uh
to latest. And of course the time 12 has
to be since we know that uh must be at
least time 11 since transaction two
started after transaction one finished
um that means that the 11 must be less
than the latest value. Um transaction
two is going to choose its latest half
as its time stamp. So it's going to
actually choose time stamp 12.
Um,
and in this example, when it does its
read, it's going to ask the storage
system, oh, I want to read as of time
stamp 12. Um, since transaction one
wrote with time stamp 10, that means
that, you know, assuming the safe
weight, uh, the safe time machinery
works, we're actually going to read the
correct value. Um, and what's going on
here is that um
the so so this happened to work out, but
indeed it's guaranteed to work out if
transaction two as long as transaction
two starts after transaction one
commits. And the reason is that commit
weight causes transaction one not to
finish committing until its time stamp
is guaranteed to be in the past. Right?
So transaction one chooses a time stamp.
It's guaranteed to commit
um at after that timestamp.
Transaction two um starts
after the commit. Um it and so we don't
know anything about what its earliest
value will be, but its latest value is
guaranteed to be after the current time.
But we know that the current time is
after the commit time of T1. um and
therefore that T2's latest value uh the
time stamp it chooses is guaranteed to
be after um when C committed and
therefore after the uh
time stamp that C used um and because
transaction two if transaction 2 starts
after T1 finishes transaction 2 is
guaranteed to get a higher time stamp um
and the snapshot isolation machinery the
multiple versions will cause it to read
um to it's read to see all lower valued
rights from all lower time stamp
transactions. That means T2 is going to
see T1 and that basically means that
we're this this is how Spanner enforces
um external consistency for its
transactions.
So any questions about this machinery?
All right. Um I want to step back a
little bit. Um there's really um from a
my point of view sort of two big things
going on here. One is snapshot isolation
by itself. Um snapshot isolation by
itself is enough to give you that is
keeping the multiple versions and giving
every transaction a time stamp. Snapshot
isolation is guaranteed to give you
serializable readonly transactions
because basically what snapshot
isolation means is that we're going to
use these timestamps as the equivalent
serial order and things like the safe
weight the safe time um ensure that
readon transactions really do read as of
their time stamps see every readr
transaction before that and none after
that. Um so there's really two pieces.
Snapshot isolation um snapshot isolation
by itself though uh is actually often
used not just by Spanner but generally
doesn't um by itself guarantee external
consistency because in a distributed
system it's different computers choosing
the time stamps. So we're not sure those
timestamps will obey external
consistency even if though they'll
deliver serializability. So in addition
to snapshot isolation, uh Spanner also
has synchronized timestamps and it's the
synchronized timestamps um plus the
commit weight rule that um allow Spanner
to guarantee external consistency as
well as serializability.
Um and again the reason why all this is
interesting is that programmers really
like transactions and they really like
external consistency because it makes
applications much easier to write. um
they traditionally not been provided in
distributed settings because they're too
slow. And so the fact that Spanner
manages to at least make readonly
transactions very fast is extremely
attractive, right? No locking, no
two-phase commit, and not even any
distant reads for readonly transactions.
They operate very efficiently from the
local replicas. And again, this is
what's good for a basically a 10 factor
of 10 uh latency improvement
um as measured in tables uh three and
six. But just to remind you, it's it's
not all um it's not all fabulous. The
the the
all all this wonderful machine only
applies to read only transactions. Read
transactions still uh use two-face
commit and locks. Um and there's a
number of cases in which even spanner
will have to block like due to the safe
time and the commit weight. Um but as
long as their times are accurate enough
uh these uh commit weights are likely to
be um relatively small.
Okay, just to summarize, the um Spanner
at the time was um kind of a
breakthrough because it was very rare to
see deployed systems that um offer you
distributed transactions where the data
was um geographically uh in uh very
different data centers. Um and
surprising, you know, Spanner people
were surprised that uh somebody was
using a database that actually did a
good job of this um and that the
performance was tolerable. um and the
snapshot isolation and the timestamping
part of the um probably the most
interesting aspects of the paper. Um
and that is all I have to say for today.
Um any last questions?
Okay. Um
I think on Thursday we're gonna we're
going to see farm which is a sort of
very different um slice through the
desire to provide very high performance
transactions.
Um,
so I'll see you all on